you were just promoting the show in
Bangkok yes I understand the show is a
big hit in in in that area of the world
it's what it felt like it was it was
pretty exciting yeah it's really quite
remarkable to go to a whole nother part
of the world and and you feel like
you're just making a little show out
here and to see that people are
responding to it and in another part of
the world a whole nother culture you
mean they apparently they part of the
reason that showed us very well in asia
is that part of the world loves all
things like zombie like zombie culture
it's very big there there that balaam
bees are huge tell you you're big in
Korea right no what do you mean I don't
trying to do actually yeah the calories
yeah it's not that was not the appeal I
didn't think I thought the appeal was
mine winning sense of humor it could be
that work on that they did that they
liked that hold they got the and that
you're like a physical stuff I did a
talk shows a Korean talk show South
Korean talk show what kind of doing your
thing there well I can see how their
India well they got that kind of dorky
physical comedy right they don't need
but somehow they make it I don't need to
sit here and listen to this okay they
make it charming maybe it's the maybe
it's the accents all right listen I
there's no reason I have to sit here and
listen to this come on I have the power
to have you physically removed
physically remove XE I don't have that
power do I gonna do it yeah yeah I'm not
gonna any agrees with you
[Laughter]
you